[موسيقى]
ما أشعر به وأنا أرقص أشعر بالحرية
، أشعر بالثقة في أنني أشعر بالقوة ،
أشعر بالتحكم في من
أنا ، علمت أن هذا ما أردت فعله ،
لم أرغب في فعل أي شيء آخر ، لكن
ربما يكون كذلك
[موسيقى]
اسمي أكيرا أرمسترونج وأنا
الرئيس التنفيذي ومؤسس حركة كبيرة جدًا
وهي شركة رقص احترافية كاملة
بدأت حركة كبيرة جدًا
منذ تسع سنوات وشعرت أنه
كان هناك فراغ ووسائط رئيسية
حيث  لم تكن منصة
للراقصين المحترفين ذوي الأحجام الزائدة التي لم أكن مناسبًا لها
حتى عند الدخول في الاختبارات
لم أشعر بأنني أنتمي
إلى نوع الجسم المعتاد المتوقع هو
راقصات الباليه التي تعرف أرجلها
الطويلة وأذرعها الطويلة وجذعها الطويل ، إنه أمر مزعج  أن
المجتمع يضع هذه التسمية على الراقصين
لأن الأمر بالنسبة لي يتعلق بالموهبة
التي حجزتها في هذه الحفلة الكبرى مع بيونسيه ، فقد
قررت جيدًا السماح لي بإجراء اختبار لمزيد من
التمثيل قمت بتجربته في
خمس وكالات مختلفة على الأقل وظلوا جميعًا
يقولون نفس الشيء إنها جيدة
ولكن  نحن لا k  الآن كيف أقوم بالتسويق لها
وقد سئمت من سماع أنه على الرغم من
أنني عانيت من الأشياء ، إلا أن
شغفي كان شغفيًا ، إلا أن شيئًا أردت
فعله هو شيء أحببته وواصلت
دفعه واستمررت في الدفع ،
ووصل الأمر للتو إلى  النقطة التي
كنت فيها هكذا هو حقًا ما أريد أن
أفعله ، لقد توصلنا إلى اسم كبير
جدًا ومن هناك قلت إنني بحاجة إلى مجموعة من
الفتيات اللائي يعرفن كيف يتحركن من يعرفن
كيف يرقصن لدينا مجموعة من السيدات الشابات اللائي يعرفن كيف يرقصن.
هم راقصون محترفون يعملون
بجد لإثبات أنفسهم ليس فقط بالنسبة لي
ولكن أيضًا لأنفسهم شيء واحد هو
أننا نفعل ذلك هو ورشة العمل الكبيرة جدًا لدينا ،
أي شخص مرحب به للحضور
إلى ورش العمل الخاصة بنا ، أنا
جميل وأنا قوي لأنني لا أشعر
سوى بالحب  هذا نحن نقوم بدوائر القوة
وهذا الجزء من ورشة العمل يصبح
عاطفيًا للغاية كل يوم
لدينا أشخاص يقولون إنني مطلقة
لقد انتحرت لقد كنت ضحية اغتصاب لقد تغلبت على
مرض السرطان لذا لن أترك هذا القتال
هم فقط  مضحك بما يكفي لجو  نشر
كل المفاهيم الخاطئة التي
لدى الناس حول النساء ذوات الحجم الزائد ، فنحن كسالى ،
ولدينا تقدير منخفض لذاتنا
[موسيقى]
لا نهتم
بمظهرنا ، فنحن غير موجودين ، ونحن موجودون هذا هو
ما أنا
عليه-  حجم ورائع
[موسيقى]